[Music]
in Deal or No Deal news deal all right
the minute by boom boom clap boom boom
hail rock you you know what's funny
where when we get into these musical
acts we all stop at the exact same time
there's always one little check you'll
get it too I'm sorry
gotta be in sync okay I'll turn it all
the way it makes very cunha that's why
you're beautiful we're gonna stop at two
bars okay
[Laughter]
all right a controversial judge is
offering inmates reduced sentences if
they agree to a vasectomy bottom photo
I mean it's reversible what with
Sunnyview a big deal it's reversible you
yes it is it's reversible
it's reversible yeah not guaranteed
though yeah it isn't mmm I mean but a
well I guess it depends on the crime if
this was going out and pregnant like 10
million people and probably I mean for a
reason okay
I was curious you can't tell me the
story
tell me about Jorge Santiago first I
watch it and guess where the stupid I'm
gonna go to Jorge where do people have
no right and viago where do people have
no right no right
America oh this happen in the US by dr.
pol and there's a clip right well then
it's Texas Georgia and Tennessee they
ever get Idol Bell Texas House come
close yeah I was going to say close but
is it really is it but yeah so there's
my judge in Tennessee that's saying that
key will reduce sentences for both male
and female by 30 days in exchange for a
sterilization procedure so for a male it
would be a vasectomy for female they
would be taking a breath control implant
that prevents prevents pregnancy for up
to four years what kind of crimes is for
now specifies just mainly it's just a
general thing the general thing so if
you rob a bank
you're like I I'm gonna get the
vasectomy alright well you were going to
be locked up for six years yeah that'll
be five years and eleven months yes I
was in well thought out without doing it
I thought it'd be like sexual predators
and my rapist
no no just any crime hasn't got anything
you've done your arm I'll take the
vasectomy I know I'm a hacker but this
is addition to those like work so maybe
there's what was it what was the judges
thought process like if this person is
criminal they're only going to produce
more criminals like people can't get rid
on I'm thinking why don't we 30 days I
know I'm not the same doesn't know kind
of I do it's like a [ __ ] rebate or
something can you can can you get get it
reversed like procedures done within 30
days of having done the vasectomy like
right afterwards - yeah master read the
fine print
I mean Michael from the authors got it
like I thought are Michael talking about
Michael from the JK off the first one of
the first money by be honest no one
night show about our office
that's the worst restaurants guys sorry
you forgot which baby was in because we
would you get to prospective Yellen
thinking Michael Scott in my head off
the pan you got three but uh so yeah so
the judges say met you just trying to
encourage personal responsibility among
inmates so they will not be burdened
with children when their release weight
like so they're going to impregnate
people in prison sort of separate it
sounds like your fault it is sound a
co-ed prisons now no conjugal visit
program started back in me and since May
there have been thirty two women who
have received the birth control implant
and thirty eight men who have agreed to
have the vasectomy but it's not clear
how many have actually had the vasectomy
I don't like it I like it but I don't
like I don't even know what it's trying
to treat that's the problem
yes of the American Civil Liberties
Union of Tennessee they've already
condemned this program saying that it's
unconstitutional they're saying quote
offering a so-called choice between jail
time and cohost contraception or
sterilization is unconstitutional such a
choice violates the fundamental
constitutional right to reproductive
anatomy and bodily integrity by
interfering with the intimate decision
of whether and when to have a child
imposing an intrusive medical procedure
on individuals who are not in a position
to reject it so you're just a corner
these people I don't know this is
[ __ ] weird I feel like if you [ __ ]
it's stupid and you keep going to jail
you shouldn't be making kids that are
going to go to jail eventually you're
assuming that I know that I know a
hundred percent [ __ ] other
statistically if you'll grandpa's a
[ __ ] criminal your your daddy's a
criminal you're going to be a [ __ ]
criminal it's generational
some people look for damn you see that
slide I just do bike through the pack I
remember when I was in high school going
to jail for some people was a rite of
passage
they're like you know what I'm not a man
unless I go to jail yet so some people
want that life you know and should they
have babies not in Jabalia [ __ ] knows
I'll get out like an x-ray the [ __ ] out
of that ball sack so
you got no more spine you know what
we're gonna we're gonna
Jesus burnt I will pick up with this
mess up this barn I'm glad you caught
them because all I did was hear it
everything was inhaling while I was
speaking okay so get ready I never
enough oh my god don't say [ __ ] like
that looks funny caution don't breathe
while you speak don't breathe inhale
while you speak when you have tender
son's pajama and wait till you end the
sentence and then inhale Oh God Laurie
sorry - oh yeah you know what you know
we need to spay and neuter people the
way that we spay and neuter dogs no
associate in Skinner versus Oklahoma's
phone they the Supreme Court had already
said that it violates the Constitution
to impose sterilization as a punishment
to criminals so even though this is this
is different because is a rebate it's on
sentencing yeah but it's still like
you're controversial it's like if you
want less than go ahead I'll give you
this option I'll give a [ __ ] what
Principal Skinner says anyway all of it
all I'm saying is it's a good choice you
know people be [ __ ] up too much yeah
I mean my personal opinion I think if
they want to then let them because it's
a choice right yeah so it's not really a
choice it is go 30 days it's not like
one year off it's kind of like a 2%
discount it don't really matter
only the cheapest Asians are going to do
it but they're also offering inmates an
additional two days off their sentencing
if they complete two days
what's that over ten years and unless
they're facing like a life-and-death
relationship in prison like there
mate I don't know maybe dead two days is
a great idea I don't know yeah well if
they complete this one program where
it's a Tennessee Department of Health
neonatal syndrome education program
which is when babies are born addicted
to drugs so they're just saying like you
know if you reach two or three people
and maybe that's two or three kids that
are saved from the syndrome so they're
saying like even though it's a little
bit at least it's worth it if it can
save someone right I can see where
they're trying to get at like the more
we educate these guys the less of a
problem they're going to be on society
well then they should really educate
that so I'm saying I think like I like I
know their intention but they're just
not executing them yeah I think they're
trying to cut corners this make you like
take tests kinda like drivers of absence
- like if there's like they could take
more classes take tests and they can
prove that they know better than maybe
they should get their substances reduces
the random program like a blanket
program - there we go
yeah that would be kind of cool it's
kind of like you know when you go on
into timeout and then you go all well
and then mom says like if you finish
your extra math problems then maybe you
can play with your video games I
remember that [ __ ] and then like maybe
we got to do that to the prisoners it's
like oh you get your timeout but maybe
wait I think I do do that
good behavior degree that was different
though because I think there's no real
like evaluation that's happening or like
set programs for them to actually learn
[ __ ] so they need to get out of jail
program so it's like it's not just time
it's like if you do the learning and if
you do these and if you do that then you
can get out though I don't know I mean I
really look as you can get into like the
the school program with the book program
you start checking out like one book a
month and then it's like one book a week
and then you start upgrading Steinmeier
kinds of LRA stuff yeah like what your
crime is and you can qualify for those
kind of things yeah if you do the time
then you do the crime I hope you guys
enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]